at the height of an elephant poaching
crisis in the 1980s richard leakey
organized a spectacular publicity stunt
as director of kenya's wildlife
authority he authorized 12 tons of
confiscated elephant tusks worth
millions of dollars to be burnt
although the practice was widely copied
globally critics said the ivory should
have been sold to fund anti-perching
efforts we can burn ivory and do all
these things but unless we can persuade
the public why we're doing it
we'll be wasting our time
ivory must be seen as only valuable if
it's on an animal
it should not be ever seen as a valuable
commodity for trade
but his implementation of a shoot to
kill policy against armed pushers made
him powerful enemies
he lost both legs when the plane he was
flying crashed in the rift valley in
what he later said was a failed attempt
to kill him
leaky's parents were the world's most
famous finers of ancient hermeneut
fossils he continued their work and it
was in a dig in kenya's turkana region
in 1975 that leaky's team discovered an
almost complete skeleton of an early
human known as homo erectus
the find helped prove humans evolved in
africa it spurred a lifelong campaign to
preserve the turkana region
it's a natural heritage site with
evidence of prehistory not just of the
ancestry of humanity but the ancestry of
the african fauna is better represented
there than anywhere in the world
he was less successful when he tried his
hand at politics in 1998 he resigned
after just two years from his position
as the head of kenya's civil service he
had attempted a crackdown on corruption
richard leakey was 77.